>>John McCutchan: Hello, everyone.
I'm John McCutchan.
I'm part of the Chrome DevRel team and my
focus is on making the web fast, and that's
what I'm hoping to teach you today: How to
make your page very fast with V8.
So this talk's going to get into some pretty
low-level details about how V8 works and how
you can surface some signals, so hopefully
that's really exciting to you because it's
exciting to me.
So today I want to talk about Oz.
Specifically, Find Your Way to Oz, the Chrome
experiment that came out in February.
Let's just take a look at a video of what
the experience is like.
This is all running inside the browser and
it's a game.
There's about four games and it's all themed
around the new Wizard of Oz movie.
So the first one is like the carnival cutout.
You put your face into this -- this wooden
painting and it's using a webcam.
Let me just kill the ad.
So the next one is a music box, and you can
actually kind of compose your own theme that,
you know, kind of fits with the Wizard of
Oz theme.
And then when you -- after you're finished,
when you're walking around throughout the
Wizard of Oz, the park, it will be playing
the song that you've made, and this is using
Web Audio.
So the next attraction at the circus is make
your own zoetrope, and for those of you who
are too young to know what a zoetrope is,
including myself, it kind of predated animation
in film and, you know, you kind of -- this
thing spun around in a circle and showed you
a very simplistic animation like this.
And again, this is using the webcam and capturing
video from your computer and then putting
you into the game world.
The final attraction is really impressive.
It's a hot air balloon ride where you have
to navigate this big tornado and, you know,
kind of escape -- Find Your Way
to Oz.
So really impressive graphics.
I mean, this looks great.
There's a really in-depth article on how they
actually accomplished this effect, and it's
very interesting.
It kind of incorporated a lot of things from
how they do effects in film where they have
like a mat painting and they're kind of composing
all of these different layers together, but
it's all running with WebGL.
So this is Find Your Way to Oz.
It's really exciting.
I recommend that you check it out.
Like I said, it's been using -- it's using
all of the latest HTML5 features.
It's using WebGL.
It was developed by unit9 and this was a partnership
between Disney and Google, and unit9 did a
great job.
It won a few awards.
It's a really exciting project.
But late in development, there was a really
serious performance problem and it wasn't
a trivial problem.
We were seeing something that -- you know,
we're looking at memory usage and seeing the
graph along the bottom here where we're just
seeing like this sawtooth-like shape where
it just keeps using more memory and the garbage
collection kicks in and cleans it up and no
one could really figure this out.
This was late.
This was not good.
The product needed to ship.
Delays were a possibility and we really had
to make sure that this -- this didn't get
out of hand.
So lucky for unit9, they were able to call
in some performance detectives and this is
Yacov and Yung from the V8 team and they were
actually able to help kind of hold unit9's
hand and figure out what was going on inside
of their game.
So I hope that you in the audience, after
going through this talk, will be able to do
the same things that unit9 did that the V8
team taught them.
So hopefully you all will become performance
detectives by the end.
So before we go into what the problem was
and how we resolved it, let's spend a few
minutes talking about why performance matters.
So if we look at a typical frame in a browser,
the first thing that happens is you have to
handle input.
The users click something or they press a
button.
After handling input, scripts start executing.
All the -- the state of the page gets updated,
and actually this often triggers a layout
change, and so the browser has to re-lay out
all the elements inside the page, and then
after this, it's got to paint all of the elements.
They're changed the contents.
What's inside of there has changed.
This is a lot of work.
And then finally, it all gets composited onto
the screen.
This just loops and you actually have to do
this 60 times a second and you have 16 milliseconds
to accomplish all of this.
If you don't, you're going to drop a frame
and you're going to get jank.
So "jank" is the slang term for like kind
of a -- an unpleasant, unsmooth site experience.
When you're scrolling on a page and it kind
of clips and it jumps, it doesn't feel smooth,
that's jank.
When you're playing an online game and it
drops a frame or some -- you know, something
kind of weird happens, it pauses for a second,
that's jank.
And so if you miss -- I mean, if you cannot
get all -- through all the steps in 16 milliseconds,
you're going to have a janky page and users
don't really like that.
So where does all this performance go?
Where does that 16 milliseconds -- where does
it go?
So if we look at this graph here, it's kind
of difficult to parse, but each column represents
a very mainstream site on the web, like Google
Docs or Gmail or Wikipedia or something like
that.
And what we really care about for this talk
is the red candy-striped section along the
bottom.
This is actually the time that your page is
spending inside V8.
And what we see is that, you know, for Google
Apps, when the page isn't idle, we're actually
spending between 50 to 70% of the time inside
idle.
And for other popular sites, it's in the range
of 20 to 40%.
So of that 16 milliseconds, a Google app is
spending 50% of it, at least, executing scripts.
So performance matters because you want your
site to grow.
You want to attract more users, and users
care about the performance of the site.
In particular, it's been highlighted, you
know, in recent times with battery life.
If you go to a page that performs poorly,
the -- you know, the battery in your mobile
device is going to drain quicker and people
are going to stop coming back because it's
just not the greatest experience.
Users also want smoother applications.
They want that, like, smooth experience when
they scroll.
They want their game to run flawlessly and
never have a hiccup on any frame.
And they want more features.
All of these things -- it's actually kind
of difficult to satisfy these requests, because
they're all sort of competing with each other.
But you as the developer, you have to satisfy
all of these requests.
It's -- you want to maximize battery life,
you want the smoothest application, and you
want the most featureful application.
And without that, you're not going to see
a really strong growth in the traffic to your
site.
So let's get back to the mystery and dig in
a little bit.
So solving a performance problem is actually
a lot like solving a crime.
The first thing you have to do is you have
to dig in and get -- collect some evidence
and really figure out what's happening.
And then from the evidence, you're going to
find some suspects, and you're going to kind
of interrogate the suspects and figure out
like which one of them is likely responsible
for your performance problem.
And then finally, you're going to go into
the forensics lab and really prove that they're
responsible and dig up some information that
will hopefully let you solve the crime and
fix the performance problem.
So let's get started on the -- the mystery
that the unit9 team faced with Oz.
So evidence collection.
You want to start off asking some pretty fundamental
questions about the site that you're looking
at.
If it's your site, then you can probably very
quickly zoom through this, but if you're helping
someone else, then you really -- it might
seem silly to start at such a basic question,
but it's important to contextualize what you're
doing.
So the -- Oz is a real-time interactive 3D
game.
It's taking advantage of WebGL.
It has to run smooth.
It has to fit that 16-millisecond time slice
or else it's going to perform badly.
So the next question you want to ask yourself,
are the developers following the best practices?
If they're not, then the likely solution to
the performance problem is probably something
really simple.
They probably just aren't aware of the best
practices and are making some silly error
and it's great.
You can fix it in no time.
But unit9 are really good developers and they
were following the best practices and they
were well-read and they were up-to-date on
all of the things that you have to do to make
a really smooth and, you know, impressive
3D game in the browser.
So it wasn't something simple.
I mean, why would I be here talking about
if it was such a trivial problem?
So specifically what kind of performance problem
are you seeing?
And when you're at this stage in your investigation,
you want to really kind of nail it down because
this is going to lead you to suspects.
And specifically, they were seeing once per
second the frame rate dropped significantly.
And to add a little bit of extra information
to it, it was actually correlated with GC
activity.
So right when the frame rate dropped, they
actually saw that the -- there was a lot of
GC activity.
Garbage collector was running.
So that gives you a bit of a clue as to maybe
where should you start your investigation.
We're seeing a frame rate drop with GC activity.
And in particular, the GC activity was massive.
Once per second.
10 megabytes of garbage was being collected.
And so you want to ask yourself, "Is 10 megabytes
per second of garbage expected?"
Because in some applications, this might be
-- that might be a reasonable amount of garbage.
In this case, it's not.
They should be generating almost no garbage
per second.
And that was what the developers' expectations
were.
So something really strange was happening
and we really needed to figure it out.
So to help us come up with suspects, we need
to understand what triggers a garbage collection,
because if we're seeing a correlation with
a performance drop with garbage collection,
we have to understand why garbage collection
happens.
So let's walk through V8 memory management
in a bit more detail and walk through a GC
pause.
So to help understand the performance characteristics
of a GC pause, we have to understand where
the cost in allocated memory comes from, and
it's not in allocating the memory itself.
That's actually really cheap.
It's incredibly fast to allocate memory in
V8.
The performance problem -- the cost of allocating
memory actually comes after a while you've
allocated enough objects and you've actually
exhausted the memory pool.
So at that point the V8 runtime is forced
to run a garbage collection and this can take
milliseconds.
And if we remember, like you have 16 milliseconds
to get through the entire frame.
You spend 5 of it doing a GC, you've lost
your frame.
You cannot recover from that.
So V8 manages memory in a generational split.
So values are split between young and old
and their age is actually kind of estimated
based on the number of garbage collections
in which they survive.
So as an object lives through collections,
it gets older.
And over time, the older values are promoted
from the young generation to the old generation.
So the young generation offers really fast
allocation, which I've already stated.
Collection is fast in relation to the cost
of an old generation collection.
And it's frequently collected.
When you're using the Chrome DevTools Timeline
panel and you see a GC event, as you can see
on the slide here that's the young generation
being collected.
In contrast, the old generation offers fast
allocation, but relative to young generation,
the collection is slower.
Luckily, though, it happens infrequently.
And part of that collection actually runs
concurrently with the mutator, which is your
JavaScript thread.
It does some incremental marking and there's
a few different types of collections that
can occur in the old generation, but typically
when you've -- when you see a frame drop in
your game or, you know, you see weird scrolling
behavior and it's a GC problem, it's the young
generation.
So let's really focus on that.
So why is collecting the young generation
so much faster?
Well, to help you understand that, you have
to -- you have to kind of intuitively understand
the cost of a GC is proportional to the number
of live objects.
So the number of objects which survive the
GC is how you can estimate how long this GC's
going to take.
So because we split the objects into two generations,
the young and the old, the young kind of,
by definition, has a very high death rate.
Very few objects survive many young generation
collections.
You know, in contrast, old generation by the
very nature of what's in the old generation,
these objects have lived for a long time so
you can't expect that, hey, let's do an old
generation collection, they're probably all
now garbage.
That doesn't make a lot of sense because they've
historically lived for a long time inside
your program.
So let's look at how the young generation
actually operates.
So the young generation is split into two
semi-spaces equally sized, the to space and
the from space.
Values are allocated from the to space, so
when your JavaScript executes a new statement,
new foo, it pulls some memory from the to
space.
The from space is used during GC and we'll
get to that shortly.
So assuming that we started with an empty
to space, it's all full of unallocated memory,
page allocates Object A and then Object B,
and then C, and D. Everything up until this
point is great.
Things are really humming along.
But unfortunately the page then tries to allocate
Object E. Now, at this point we've actually
exhausted the amount of memory in the young
generation and we cannot do this.
So things back up a little bit.
Object E wasn't allocated because there just
wasn't room for it.
The page is paused.
Everything stops.
The rendering stops like exactly at that line
of code where you called new.
Everything pauses.
A collection gets triggered.
So the first thing in a collection is that
the from and the to space, they're just swapped.
The labels are swapped.
The old from space, which is empty, becomes
the new to space.
The next stage is that all the live values
inside the young generation are discovered.
These are marked and the next step is to copy
them.
And this is where a lot of the time is actually
spent.
It's in this copy.
And this is what -- when I said earlier that
the cost of the GC is proportional to the
number of objects which survive, you have
to copy these objects across from one space
to the other, and this is where a lot of that
time goes.
So in this example, A and C survived and we've
copied them to the new to space and here we
go.
The page can resume and allocate Object E.
So what you intuitively have to understand
is that each allocation moves you closer to
this pause.
So if you're dealing with a -- you know, something
where timing really matters, you almost want
to operate under the assumption that you cannot
allocate memory.
You want to kind of preallocate everything
ahead of time.
Because the collection completely pauses your
application, and this brings higher latency,
so just imagine that a user clicks a button
and then right then inside your click handler
you allocate some new object.
Boom, you've hit the GC pause and like these
are actually fields.
Like "Hey, I clicked," and there's just this
moment where nothing is happening and it offers
a bad user experience.
In games, you get dropped frames.
You know, ultimately this just leads to unhappy
users who may not come back to your site.
So now that we understand what happens in
a GC pause and how you get to a GC pause,
it's time to start looking at some suspects.
And we've got these sneaky guys right here
-- blue, red, and green -- who are incognito.
So the first suspect is pretty -- you know,
this should really jump to your mind at this
point -- is just calling new.
Maybe Oz is calling new all the time and they're
just like allocating all of these objects
throughout the frame and then, like, they're
triggering the GC pause and they haven't retained
references to any of these objects, so they're
all just garbage and it gets collected and
that's where that 10 megs come from.
So a careful audit of the code base confirmed
that there was no calls to new within the
frame.
And actually unit9 said that would have been
really embarrassing, and this goes back to
them being -- they're following the best practices.
They're well aware of what they should and
shouldn't be doing inside their game.
So suspect Number 2 is code running in unoptimized
mode.
And let's talk about why this is a suspect.
If we look at JavaScript on the slide, we
can see that there is some computation and
they calculate A and B and C and then they
do some multiplication and update the X position
of some sprite in the game.
So in unoptimized mode, there is actually
a lot of implicit memory allocations.
Why we don't see any calls to new on the slide,
there is actually behind the scenes many calls
to new or their equivalent.
So, when we calculate P times D, a new object
is allocated.
Similarly, for C plus 3 and 3.3 times dt,
new objects are being allocated at each one
of these points.
It is not clear to you as a developer when
you are looking at the code, but this is actually
what's happening behind the scenes.
And then even when we calculate A times B,
it is not assigned anywhere; but, still, memory
is reserved for the result.
And then the result there is multiplied with
C. More memory is allocated.
In contrast, if this function was running
in optimized mode, there would actually only
be a single memory allocation and that's what
the final result is assigned to the field
inside the object.
You can see that there is a huge difference
between the amount of memory that is churned
through in unoptimized mode compared to optimized
mode.
And actually V8 recently optimized for this
case so only the first time that X is updated
will memory be allocated.
So it has got even better.
So let's walk through, like, how you transition
between unoptimized mode and optimized mode
and exactly kind of what's the state machine
under the hood.
So all code starts off unoptimized.
The first time your function runs, it is always
going to be unoptimized.
That's fine.
After a little while though, V8 will say,
Hey, this function is actually pretty hot,
meaning it is executing a lot.
And it is going to attempt to optimize that
function.
So it is going to transition from the unoptimized
state to the optimized state.
But as is kind of natural in JavaScript, there
is occasionally some deoptimization events.
Some assumption that was baked into the optimization
has been violated so then the function gets
kicked back over to the unoptimized state.
This is actually okay.
This kind of naturally happens throughout
JavaScript's execution lifetime.
And then, again, after a little while, V8
says, You know what?
I have got some better information with this
function.
It is still pretty hot.
Let me try to optimize it in a better way
so we can handle both of the cases that we've
seen so far.
Unfortunately, what happens is that after
too many de-optimizations, your function actually
just gets sent down to unoptimized hell and
you never get to escape.
Like, once you are in this place, that's it,
you are always going to run in unoptimized
mode.
There are also other ways to get into unoptimized
hell.
You can use certain code constructs.
We will see an example in a little bit.
But if your function has a try catch block
in it, V8 today just doesn't optimize for
that.
So right away as soon as the function is seen
by V8, it just gets slotted into, you know,
permanently unoptimized state and it is just
going to sit there.
These constructs could be optimized for, but
it just hasn't been a priority up to this
point.
So we've definitely got a potential suspect
here.
It's possible that some code inside Oz is
running in unoptimized mode.
And, you know, there actually is no way to
surface this using Chrome DevTools.
You can't figure out just looking inside the
dev panel, Hey, this function is unoptimized.
Let's fix it.
So we have a potential suspect.
So the third suspect is a common JavaScript
performance strap and that's actually modifying
object shape.
So if we -- V8 behind the scenes creates these
hidden classes for objects.
So the point constructor assigns the X field
and then the Y field.
And that -- that order, the sequence of assigning
the fields in the constructor generates the
class ID.
So A little bit later on after constructing
P, somewhere in the program, someone just
adds a new field to the P object, which is
completely fine inside JavaScript.
But that new field inside P, that instance,
creates a new class ID.
So this is going to trigger a deoptimization.
So let's walk through kind of what happens.
This calls back to that state machine we were
just looking at.
So at first we see this point object, the
class ID for it.
And code is running in unoptimized state because
it is the beginning of execution and that's
expected.
So after a little bit of time, V8 detects
that some functions using point are hot and
let's optimize for them.
But then the shape is modified.
And this point prime class is created.
So now there's two point classes kind of floating
around inside the internal state of V8.
There's point with XY and there is point with
XYZ.
So the next time a call site sees this point
prime class when it is expecting a point class,
it actually de-optimizes and we go across
that graph back to the unoptimized state.
But after a little while, the code is optimized
to support both point and point prime classes.
So, again, a careful audit confirmed there
were no shape changes.
This is a really common JavaScript performance
trap.
And, again, the unit9 guys were really well-read.
So it is not surprising that this was not
the problem.
And in some ways, suspect Number 3 is a special
case of suspect Number 2.
So suspect Number 1, calling new, its alibi,
wasn't even at the crime scene.
No one was doing that.
Suspect Number 2 has no alibi.
So it seems like a pretty likely suspect at
this point.
And the third one, suspect Number 3, shape
change, again, not at the crime scene so we
are really narrowing in.
It really seems likely that a big chunk of
code is running in unoptimized mode.
And now we need to get to the lab and prove
this.
So there is a lot of tools that you can use
to help diagnose and really dig into performance
problems.
First is Chrome DevTools.
And that's the panel that you can bring up
inside Chrome, and it ships with Chrome.
But this is a real performance mystery, so
we're just going to jump right past it.
We are already past Chrome DevTools.
The next is about tracing.
And this is a really great tool for diagnosing
the internal GPU state inside Chrome and some
other really low-level information.
But, again, like, we're past this.
This is a really strange performance problem.
So we've got to jump right down to the nitty-gritty.
We have got to go to the V8 tools.
The V8 tools actually ship with V8 source
code.
So if you want to use these tools, you have
to go to Google code and grab V8 and compile
it and then you get access to these tools.
As we will see, these tools were necessary
to diagnose this performance problem.
So what we want to do is we want to confirm
that unoptimized code is running and then
determine why that code isn't being optimized.
So the first thing we want to do is we want
to capture a V8 timeline.
And the way you do that is you run Chrome
with this crazy command line flag, Chrome,
no Sandbox, JS flags, prof, noprof2-lazy,
log-timer events.
Kind of strange but it gives you a lot of
really good information.
So after running Chrome with this and you
run your site for a little while, you close
it down.
Inside the directory that you launched Chrome
from will be a v8.logfile.
This is a text file which you are free to
open up and look inside but it is a little
bit cryptic.
So V8 ships with some tools that will parse
this logfile and generate really useful information
for you.
So after running plot timer events on the
log, you are going to get a PNG that actually
shows you a big timeline of the state of V8
and what's happening.
So let's kind of walk through what's in this
diagram here.
So along the left-hand side are rows representing
different states that V8 is executing in.
And you will see a colored vertical tick whenever
V8 is in that state.
So along the top is some different garbage
collector states.
And I have arrowed out the scavenger, and
that's the young generation collection.
Along the bottom there, you can see the V8.execute
state and that's when it is executing script
code.
You will see, though, where the blue line
for the scavenger, you can actually see that
there is a blank spot on the execute.
And this fits with our understanding of the
way GC works.
When GC is active, your script isn't executing.
So along the middle is this colored band showing
you the code kind.
And this is really helpful because we suspect
that we're running some unoptimized code and
looking at the timeline.
It really does look like we are.
So the bright green is optimized code.
So when you see that across, you know that
everything executing across those ticks is
optimized.
What we see in the graph is we see this blue-purply
kind of color, and this is unoptimized code.
And it is executing in different stubs and
different runtime methods inside V8.
So it looks like our hunch was correct and
that we are executing some unoptimized code.
So if we look at the transition where we switch
from running optimized code to unoptimized
code, it might be difficult to see on the
slides because that's a little bit blown out.
But you can actually see that there is a whole
bunch of scavenges across that time slice.
You can actually see there are little gaps
in the execution that fit perfectly with when
these scavengers were occurring.
So here we are.
Oz is running smoothly.
And then we are at that one-second mark and
it hiccups down and it starts running unoptimized
code for some reason.
And we can see that there is all these scavenges,
and this fits exactly with what we saw inside
Chrome DevTools.
Another really helpful piece of information
inside the timeline is this graph along the
bottom.
And this is the pause times graph.
So you can see at the beginning, there is
actually a whole bunch of pause times.
You can see these black vertical bars sticking
up on the bottom on the left-hand side.
That's when it is parsing the script, and
it is actually just getting going.
And then we're in optimized function time.
You don't see any pause times there.
It is just this flat curve.
And then right when we transition into running
unoptimized code and we see all these scavenges,
we also see correlated spikes in pause times.
So you can see that the scripts have stopped
executing right when the scavenges occur,
right when we transition to unoptimized code.
So now we need to figure out what function
is that?
I mean, we've confirmed that there's unoptimized
code running.
But we really have to nail down who is responsible
for it.
So, again, we run Chrome with the same command
line flags but this time we take the V8 log
and we run the Mac tick processor.
And so when you download V8 and you build
it, you are going to get a tick processor
for whatever platform you build it on.
So there is a Windows one, a Linux one.
In this case, we are on a Mac so we will run
the Mac tick processor.
When you run that on the V8 log, you actually
get this nice helpful table of functions sorted
by how frequently they're seen by the profiler.
So next to drawsprites, you see this asterisk;
and that indicates that the function in question
is optimized.
But if we look at the top, this is the function
that is running the most -- most often in
the profile capture.
Updatesprites doesn't have a asterisk next
to it.
So this seems like the likely culprit here.
Something in updatesprites is causing it not
to be optimized.
And so let's try to figure out what's going
on.
So, how can we determine why a function is
not optimized?
This is actually where it gets a little hairy.
You run Chrome with a different set of flags
you run with trace deopt and trace opt verbose.
What happens is actually a lot of text just
gets dumped to the terminal that you launched
Chrome from.
It is just this wall of text.
You likely want to pipe it to a text file
and look at it later on.
But digging through that, we looked for updatesprites
and we actually found that, Hey, here's this
line that says "disabled optimization for
updatesprites, reason: Forinstatement is not
the fast case."
It seems kind of cryptic at this point, but
I think when we look at the source code of
updatesprites, we might get a better idea
of what's going on.
So, here's equivalent of the problem code
in Oz.
We have this function updatesprites.
And it just iterates using a for-in loop across
the sprites array.
And then inside of this loop, it just does
a bunch of arithmetic.
And if we remember earlier, when you are running
in unoptimized mode and you are performing
arithmetic, you actually are allocating all
of these objects, like, just for temporary
values that aren't being stored anywhere.
And here we see this for-in statement.
And this function was not being optimized
specifically because of this loop construct.
And earlier when I was showing you the diagram
of the different states that your functions
can be in inside V8, there is way to get into
unoptimized hell by just using a code construct
that V8 doesn't optimize for today.
It is not that V8 can't optimize for it, but
it just hasn't yet.
So this seems like we've kind of found our
suspect here.
It is this single line of code, is triggering
V8 to say, You know what?
I can't optimize this.
I will just treat it as an unoptimized function.
We couldn't really have this.
So, ah, yes, arithmetic has implicit allocations.
So the fix is actually really simple.
You just move the arithmetic into its own
function and this function doesn't have the
forinstatement so it can actually be optimized
by V8.
And we can leave that for-in loop inside the
unoptimized function and just call the updatesprite
method.
So if we look at the memory of such graph
before and after, we can see a really clear
difference.
We're no longer seeing this huge sawtooth
spike up and then come down with a GC.
We are seeing a nice, natural growth curve
which -- which you want to see.
So case closed, right?
I mean, we figured it out.
But, actually, the GC pause time was a bit
of a red herring because the real performance
problem was that all this arithmetic was executing
in unoptimized mode.
That's just significantly slower.
So, the GC pause time actually led us to fixing
the problem but it wasn't the problem in itself.
But it was a really, really simple fix.
I mean, you saw how simple it was.
Just move the loop body into its own function.
It was great.
But what was really helpful and what I hope
you can take away from this talk is that unit9,
the developers who built Oz, they understood
how to look under the hood.
They understood how to pull out all this information
and surface these signals inside V8.
And they on their own without the help of
the V8 team were able to go and identify many
other functions which would have got stuck
in deoptimization hell and just generally
improved the performance of their code.
So in conclusion, V8 offers three tools.
There's the timeline plot tool which is this
bird's eye view of V8 activity.
There is the tick processor, which is going
to give you a table of hot functions.
And, remember, there is a asterisk next to
the functions which are optimized.
If you are running into a similar problem,
you are going to want to look for functions
that lack the asterisk.
And then the deoptimization log.
This actually gives you deep insight into
the optimization state machine that we looked
at previously.
So, solving a performance problem is just
like solving a crime in real life.
You first have to start with evidence collection.
And it is really important to ask the right
questions because you might start going down
the path that leads you to no performance
improvement.
After you've collected the right set of evidence,
you move on to suspects.
You try and narrow it down to a few likely
culprits.
And then after interrogating your suspects,
you want to move on to the forensics lab and
use these tools to prove your case.
So, of course, you want to start with Chrome
DevTools and then maybe about tracing before
you get to V8.
But sometimes these performance problems are
so mysterious that the only way that you're
going to be able to solve them is by using
these tools that we just covered.
So thank you.
[ Applause ]
So don't forget to check out perf alley.
And we have a few minutes for questions.
But afterwards, I will be up doing some Chrome
office hours upstairs.
If you have any questions, please come to
the mic.
>>> Hi.
So I'm curious if I used -- if I had used
a closure compiler to compile my JavaScript,
does it automatically figure out that these
constructs could lead to unoptimized code
and remove them?
Or what happens?
>>John McCutchan: That's actually a good question
for the closure team.
>>> Uh-huh.
>>John McCutchan: But I would hope that some
constructs they are aware are slower.
Of course, it varies over which JavaScript
engine is executing the code.
>>> Okay.
>>John McCutchan: Everyone has a slightly
different performance profile.
>>> I mean, is there some or any static analysis,
some kind of tool I could put my JavaScript
into to tell me when I'm using constructs
like this?
Because it seems like this you could have
caught very easily without actually running
it, right?
>>John McCutchan: Well, in some sense, yeah,
it does kind of seem that way.
You will note that the message was actually
-- the forinstatement is not the fast case.
So the fact that it couldn't be optimized
really depended on the runtime behavior.
But I agree, it would be nice to have a static
analysis tool that was kept current with JavaScript
engines because this is always changing.
So you wouldn't want to have a tool that's
a year old because some of the advice might
just be wrong.
>>> Right, okay.
Cool.
>>> Hi, I'm James Harding.
I was wondering, is there a way that you can
tell V8 you are going to allocate a bunch
of objects, especially like if a user goes
to a page where, like, the developer, like,
we know that there's going to be thousands
of objects that are going to be allocated
when they visit that page, is there any way
to sort of optimize that?
>>John McCutchan: There is no way to tell
V8, hey, I'm going to allocate thousands of
objects, don't do any GC.
What you could do is at that initial -- when
the page is first loading and the scripts
are first executing, you can preallocate a
lot of these objects and then keep them around.
>>> Okay, thank you.
>>> So this kind of goes back to the first
question.
You said that static tools probably wouldn't
be good because, I mean, the advice changes,
right?
I mean, the engine changes and what was good
before is no longer good.
But I see that same problem with something
like this, right?
Like, you make that change now, but that change
that you made now is no longer good in the
future?
Right?
Because this changes a lot, like the V8 engine.
>>John McCutchan: Yeah, so it does.
But what I'm trying to get across here is
how to use these tools to uncover any performance
problem.
>>> Yeah.
>>John McCutchan: Not just highlight this
for-in loop.
>>> Right.
Do you think that V8 -- I don't know how to
say this -- is stable enough to, like, justify
that?
Because, I mean, I wouldn't want to do something
like this, which is quite a bit of investment,
to have, like, two months later, like -- I
don't know a lot about V8.
Do you think it is stable enough that this
kind of investment is worth it?
>>John McCutchan: Well, again, this work was
done because the performance was bad already.
>>> Uh-huh.
>>John McCutchan: So, I mean, that's the first
question you should ask yourself, is: Are
things performing fine?
In which case, you should stop, because great,
there is no problem.
But V8 does change a lot.
But I wouldn't expect V8 to take something
that once ran fast and make it run slow.
>>> Okay.
Thanks.
>>> Hi.
I'm (saying name) from LinkedIn Mobile.
I'm curious, what are you guys doing with
the Chrome DevTools to help bring better some
of the P analysis and performance analysis
to node GAS?
Because right now there's a lot of community
projects out there that kind of attempt to
do that.
It would really be nice if there was a Google-blessed
way of profiling V8 in node GAS for long-running
processes in memory management.
>>John McCutchan: That would be nice, but
I'm not the right person to ask that question.
I think it would be great, too.
We have a question at the back microphone
now.
>>> Yeah.
So these tools look really cool.
I would like to use them.
I don't particularly want to download V8 to
do so.
Do you know if there are any plans to source
this sort of information in Chrome?
It seems like it would be useful to Chrome
--
[ Multiple people speaking simultaneously
]
>>John McCutchan: There is discussions about
how we can surface some of these signals into
Chrome DevTools or maybe about tracing so
you don't have to go and grab the V8 source
code.
But it's going to be kind of like this -- it
is going to be a continuous transition so
you could still get into situations where,
you know, we've surfaced a whole bunch of
signals but you still need to go and grab
the tools to find that one signal that we
haven't surfaced yet.
But yeah.
We're aware of the desire to have this stuff
come up into DevTools.
All right.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]